we have another story we'll talk about
why desantis approaching this woke stuff
is so important we have a story here
from daily mail this is an ongoing saga
about a transgender swimmer
demolishing female records that email
reports exclusive the integrity of
women's sports is at stake distressed
parents of you penn swimmers pen
poignant letter demanding the ncaa
change rules that have permitted
transgender athlete leah thomas to
dominate the competition good for those
parents good for those parents
especially so i i think the issue right
here right now the don't i don't take
issue with with um
on the surface with leah thomas
competing because the rules were set and
people did not participate in the rule
changes or what was going on but but
were they even aware that that's their
fault so
yep i don't know though look people i
understand what you're saying as
somebody who's super duper involved
there's still stuff that's happening
that like that i'm unaware of and i'm a
political nerd that's like in stuff all
the time how many years have we been
talking about this and so do you think
that these you penn parents listen to
you to you some of them maybe maybe
it should be
but but i think that you can you can't
assume
that i think it is a wrong assumption to
take that the average parent who is
working two jobs to send their kid to
upenn
um is is really aware of oh hey the ncaa
changed rules that's interesting you
know that the left is so good at
sneaking this
[ __ ] in and they do it
sure that's besides the point look if
you're a parent and you are dedicating
you are you were talking about the lives
of your children and you are like i'm
gonna send you to a school and i don't
know what the rules are i don't know
when the meetings are i don't know the
rule changes are happening then i feel
like you are being but these weren't you
pen changes they were these were ncaa
changes i don't know so i need to like
find this out because i would be curious
to know like was it public and no
because stuff like this happens and then
they should have immediately the moment
they went into that swim meet or
whatever that was there was a dude there
and they said no no no no no we're not
doing this what's going on and they
didn't they said just compete anyway and
these female swimmers are
are not standing up and speaking out
they're just giving anonymous comments
if you're not gonna stand up for
yourself if you're not gonna speak out
about this and if you are a parent who
doesn't know look when it comes to the
ncaa we're talking about your child's
future we're talking about how you have
been coaching your child and putting in
a program to make them the best of the
best in whatever sport they're engaged
in and you don't know about what's going
on i'm sorry after how many years has it
been that we've been having these
conversations you still don't know
negligence but at this point isn't it
the parent they're they're adults now
these these students that's right the
parents responsibility anymore i think
that's true but it's the parents dollars
right yeah maybe and and maybe in this
condition unless they took out a loan
eighty thousand dollars take a look
that's insane everybody is scared the
mom added parents are all are also
scared the kids will be harmed we are
paying 80 000 for this school their life
will be impacted that wouldn't be the
case if you would just stand up and say
no but we've had three of three female
swimmers come out anonymously and be
like we don't like this but let's let's
future trip here a little bit
what happens then because i'm definitely
a person that
i'm fine with standing up and saying no
i am the person i have dug my political
grave i will lie in it but part of what
i do is i feel like i have to be and i
am representative of women in stem and
in hollywood and in fashion and in
finance who will legitimately lose
everything if they speak up and say no
and i think that you are now especially
the heck yay for virginia with the
yonkin situation seeing people that are
saying okay especially when it comes to
our kids enough is enough
i think that for these parents you can't
underestimate that them writing a letter
to the administration that could behind
the scenes or very publicly much to the
cheering of the sjws of the world how
many years though tim it's been going on
for a decade
over a decade joe rogan
joe rogan on his show
joe rogan on his show and this is back
in 2012 talked about fallon fox crushing
a woman's skull in an mma ring joe rogan
is the biggest podcast in the world this
is mainstream and these parents had
there's there is no way you will ever
convince me they didn't know this
happening the only reason they're
speaking on this letter is because it's
finally impacting them and now they have
that's most people most people don't say
or do anything like those women in in
virginia once again that voted for
yunkan that also voted for joe biden
they flipped in the last two weeks
because it affected them that that's
just human nature and i don't think that
you're gonna change that and i don't
think that we're gonna win people to do
more of this
telling them that they're negligent
parents they are negligent parents when
their kids have been training throughout
high school and now entering college and
they were like don't worry we'll keep
our heads down let me explain when when
benjamin franklin said those who would
give up their freedoms for temporary
security deserve neither and will lose
both that doesn't just apply to the
government it it exists in every facet
these people who think i'll keep my head
down and scrape by you are sacrificing
your principles you are sacrificing the
future for your children
now when it comes now you think hold on
you think i'm gonna i'm gonna allocate
resources in defense of people who knew
this was going on it's been going on for
a decade and they are now saying oh no
now my kids are losing races sorry leah
thomas has abided by all of the rules
undergoing a year of hormone treatment
so that she could qualify for this and
where were the parents to come out and
say no to this oh i'm sorry you're
saying the parents weren't paying
attention to the rules that they were
putting i'm not saying i'm saying that
could be option a option b could just be
the
they think this too shall pass i think
that there is an element of people
especially over the age of like 40 45 in
this country they're like it didn't used
to be this way this this ain't gonna be
a thing this will go away and that now
they're waking up and realizing oh this
ain't going away and we need to do
something so i respect the letter
absolutely 100 the parents who are
coming out now now being like this is
wrong they're scared and i wish the
female athletes would speak up if i
i would totally wish they would but i
get that everyone's cost benefit
analysis is different and if these girls
go on and start a gaming company and are
actually legitimate successful real
feminist business owners that don't
discriminate against people and have
intellectual like like diversity at
their companies amazing they have to
like think about the ends here before
they say something and i don't and this
is why they want to undermine people
this is why
the the the moderates independence the
libertarian types are losing culturally
or at least have been for some time
because the left is willing to go
scorched earth they'll literally send
shock troops with crowbars and molotov
cocktails to get what they want they
will put their names on giant signs and
say this is who i am and i refuse when
they go to work uh there was one person
who went to taco bell working there and
wore a black lives matter mask and the
boss said you can't wear that it's
political and they said i'm wearing it
or i'm i'm quitting and they said you're
fired he said fine took a picture posted
online the entire left rallied around
him got his job back and forced the
company to bend its knee the right just
says but
but you know but i got to think about
feeding my kids in the future so i'm not
going to engage in this and they lose
lose lose i i agree with most of that i
just think that you have to be
understanding of the people that have to
feed their kids and don't want to lose
their future and so we need to be more
organized we need to be better at a
narrative and we need to be
understanding that emotional
um stories and emotional examples can
can kind of engage people and get them
in and then you can fill them with facts
and encourage them to speak up well sure
sure but where where this attitude that
i've heard of consistently over the past
few years of if i speak up i could lose
my job and how do i feed my kids and i'm
like have you looked at the cost of
cereal it's going up 20 percent have you
look at the the wholesale inflation's up
nearly 10 the fastest on record consumer
price uh in increases are up at a
40-year high inflation is about to run
away they've they've printed what 30 to
40 percent of all u.s dollars in the
past year and a half and people keep
saying
but i got to make sure there's food for
my kids yo if you keep complying with
this you're not going to have anything
for your kids and i'm saying this is
where you and the joes and the benz and
the and the rogans of the world can give
these people than the talking points and
the encouragement that they need to
actually say something because i think
especially for women we totally like
second guess ourselves and we are like
did that happen did that hap oh i don't
know did the teacher really say that
like did that kid really say that to my
kid and like should i say something well
i don't know i don't want to lose a
friend and all this stuff and we are
like in the moment of just life that we
are think that we don't have the voice
and are afraid that we don't have i get
told this all the time by people
specifically women that are like i feel
like i can't say what you say because i
won't sound as good saying it i'm like i
don't even say it that good i don't know
what you all are talking about but i
think that
people like us have to use our voices
and give these people the talking points
and the help that they need to go
scorched earth and to show it to the
companies that we're not going to put up
with this anymore i agree with that the
challenge is if the
lowest tier of antifa and the leftists
random people on the internet are
willing to plaster their names their
sacred honor and their families behind
their principles and the and the other
side the independent libertarian types
are not willing to do that then it's
clear which side is going to dominate
the culture war yeah but are they really
i see lots of like empty twitter faces
and profiles that that tweak major
companies you know trying to get to stop
like and they wear masks and they have
strategy yeah but these are people who
are willing to go out on january 20th
2017 and and burn and torch vehicles and
smash windows and when they got arrested
institutional powers that they've
organized got them all released except
for those who pled guilty ignorantly and
then you look at what happens with you
know as a right-wing group can can walk
outside for a march holding up signs
saying peace and love and they'll say
it's a far-right nazi rally
so the the these people have ceded that
power to the establishment media they're
not working in in these industries and
look
if you're not willing to engage i don't
know
i will point this out too
obviously the left has the high ground
because they have literally yeah and
that's why we have to be smart and
absolutely absolutely they don't just
have the media though they have all of
the other industries in which i
mentioned that scared women messaged me
every day right stem education fashion
but my finances so so while i recognize
there are some you know strategic limits
yep what do you think would have
happened if as soon as this race so this
leah thomas won the race by over 38
seconds compared to the next fastest
rifle like when i was watching a video
of this i saw people swimming the wrong
way and i was confused because i've
watched swimming before i've watched
like you know olympic races oh didn't
they all dive off the same uh-huh and
then they go back and they go back and
they go back and i'm like why is this
person going back
oh they're just outlapping the other
people that whoa
what has happened
what do you think would have happened if
all of the women who were there refused
to race
oh it they probably would have been
kicked out of school that's my
assumption you think that the schools
would have been like they're not racing
you kicked out i think no i think they
would have been like there's no race i
think that that's well there's no race
but then all the sjws and all of the
woke people on twitter and all of the
corporations that maybe sponsor the team
and uh any of the coaches or the medical
staff or you know the groups on campus
the lgbtq groups would have
outed those girls and made their lives
miserable and if they weren't kicked out
by the administration they would have
been scared to ever set foot on that
campus that's what would have happened
they deserve to lose
absolutely well if if you if you are
unwilling to sacrifice and take personal
responsibility for your future and for
what you believe in then you don't
deserve it and i hope that i'm raising
my girls our motto every day is to be
strong sweet and smart that they have
the independence and the forethought and
the inner strength to do what is right
but i think that ostracizing people by
belittling the small steps that they're
willing to take and saying well you're
not risking enough is not going to win
more people to our side either they're
unwilling to stand up for what they
believe in
this letter for them is like what
they're willing the parents aren't the
adult ian made a good point these people
are competing our adults they're
responsible for themselves if you're
look you but you know money talks so if
the parents are the ones paying 80 grand
a year really the parents saying
something maybe makes more of a
difference than the girls saying i'm not
gonna swim there are so many people you
know when you were mentioning it's like
you know you said me joe ben and people
who speak up and bring these things up
if you're gonna sit back and say someone
else will do it for me i guarantee you
you will lose oh absolutely and that's
that's literally how what i spend every
day is like i am here to speak for a lot
of people but like we need more of us
and we need more average people and
there is strength in numbers so it's
it's hard for me to be up look so my
personal opinion is there should be a a
women's fee but you know female division
and then there's a male division and
maybe we do a trans division where you
know it can be mixed
but
right now
if the rules were changed but by the way
sorry sidebar if if you're a woman that
is transitioning to a man you're still
not going to beat the man that's
transitioning to a woman so there should
be a transit of it have we
no this is the the biological female who
started transitioning to become male
testosterone ends up with broad
shoulders muscle mass and all that stuff
when you comp i i think there's there's
obviously going to be some research into
this but it is true that biological
males who undergo hormone therapy do
have reduced muscle mass and stamina and
drugs etc and then females who undergo
of course therapy gain it so there might
be you know immediately i don't think so
i think genetically and naturally there
are so many scientific differences that
are just in our bodies as men and women
in in those like two sexes that it there
there can't be i don't think be trouble
regardless right and that's huge and
that's true but you have high definition
cellulite muscles like your
body like your bones
everything if we create a new division
that people can choose to enter then
they're free to choose to enter it or
not i'm okay with that sure yeah so if
it's a pub if it is a public school i
think unfortunately this is gonna start
coming over to
much like they did with the gay marriage
thing
and
sex education and crt it's going to
start inkling its way if it hasn't
already and i think in some places it
has into religious schools as well i
want to give a shout out to clifton
duncan who tweeted something i think is
really great he said my contempt for
covidiens has been surpassed by my
contempt for people who know something
is wrong and stay silent
and i was like yep
but uh you know what ends up happening
is
when people are unwilling and outside of
the issue of these schools we'll move on
from that when people are unwilling to
stand up for any of these issues what
you end up with with you end up with
hyper individualism people basically
saying if no one else is willing to
rally and defend this i'm on my own i'm
going to stay on my own well and but
that can be so once again like
going back to how women are so different
than men that anxiety and that isolation
can be so paralyzing
and and i think that it all all it takes
is my i would just tell anybody like
just find a person
that agrees with you on something you
don't have to clearly you and i don't
agree on on everything but
i hope we walk away friends after this
and we're gonna like fight the cause
together after this right because we
agree on the majority of things that
need to be done to make the country a
better place and to keep it the greatest
station in the world and so i think that
people you're right they become
lackadaisical and they become lazy and
they become isolationists in a sense
because they think that they are all
alone in their thinking and they don't
see anyone else speaking up and so i
just want to encourage more parents and
more swimmers and more everybody to
speak up in any way that you possibly
can because then more of those voices
make a difference like look at all those
incredible parents that were like i'm
gonna go to my local school board
meeting yep and that made an
impact and they're winning yeah and we
need more of them thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you